fade has been invalerant for a little
under a month now but she just might be
the one thing valerian needed valerant
had a problem a sova problem and now
she is here to fix it
hey everyone it's liz it is with a heavy
heart that i inform you that i cannot
play valorem this week because my nails
i'm also having a bit of trouble
reaching that like button the subscribe
button and that notification bell so you
can just ring that for me that would be
great
all right i'm going to lay down one rule
and one rule only
no thirsty fade comments i am tired of
giving out bonks bunk bunk
bunk if you don't know who fade is she
is the newest valorant agent and she
brings a whole new way of initiating to
the squad let's do a super quick rundown
of her kit her signature or haunt is
like a sofa dart basketball she has two
prowlers which are guidable and when
they spot someone they attack and
nearsight them then there's her seize
which i call the ball which if thrown
and if it catches someone within its
diameter makes them stuck in that circle
not only that held enemies are deafened
and decayed and then we have her alt
basically it's aoe is a large portion of
the map and leaves a trail to the
enemies this trail then can allow any
prowlers you have left to go directly to
them in addition to this the ult if it
hits an enemy deafens and decays them
really really long story short if you're
within the alts aoe you're
sorry so all of this util and it's
perfect not only is fade a baddie she is
exactly what this game needed here's
what i mean by that before fade came
along valerian had a bit of a sova
problem silva barely had any nerfs to
him besides most recent patch and even
that one isn't that big of a deal sova
by far was the best initiator an
infographer don't get me wrong reach sky
kale they're all great but as an
independent initiator sobo was
unbeatable even way back when tens was
on cloud nine and had blonde hair sofa
was a problem so it was actually
probably the most busted character in
the game right now and the by far the
most annoying character to play against
sure sky and more recently breach were
better picks on some maps but no one
quite did the job like sova of space
making and infographing sova like jet
were the defining agents of valerian and
people latched on to them for the simple
reason that they were the best agents of
their class there will always be lower
tier picks that's reality of hero based
games but no one pick should dominate
there should always be clear advantages
and disadvantages for every agent but
when it came to sova there was never
really not a reason to pick him so with
all of that being said how has fade
fixed the problem
well two ways the first way is her
infograbbing is just as good if not
better than soba's her eye does the same
job as his recon dart and her prowlers
kind of act like a sky dog second is
that she is more of a team player sova
is so good at being independent and his
util is extremely self-sufficient this
is where fade really shines yeah she's
an infographer with her haunt but her c
and her q only really work to the best
of their ability when she has allies
that push forward with them or use util
to capitalize on them like this combo
raised nade and fade ball
[Laughter]
this is why you see a lot of teams
running a ko fade combination one is a
more self-sufficient close quarters
initiator while the other info grabs and
helps set him up and other agents for
success basically fade is just as good
and a team player a number of her
abilities apply statuses to players that
sobas do not while silva is damage
dealing fade is play making both are
great but it's harder for teammates to
capitalize on sovie's abilities beyond
the recon volt with fades you capitalize
on the debuffs at the end of the day
fade gives the game more team comp
options that aren't sacrificing anything
in fact she might be gaining something
with her win rate across all ranks
averaging at 49.26 percent so by using
comparison is forty eight point eighty
three percent now fetus enough
considerably less time and it makes
sense that urban rate is a bit higher
since we're all still getting used to
her the fact is she's still pretty
comparable lower tier agents like
phoenix don't have as high of a win rate
and it is simply because his kit isn't
as good sorry phoenix mains this man
needs some tender love and care from
riot because he sucks not you
the agent you you're great you're you're
doing spectacular fade does not replace
silva she is another choice and that is
exactly what we needed another choice
besides fancy arrow man having choice
makes the game more exciting comps
become a thinking man's dream no game
should pigeonhole you into selecting
specific heroes they get different info
in different ways right like
silva has the dart and she's got her
eyeball but her eyeball is not better
than the darts but
silva has a drone
fate has two drones technically
they're not as good
but there's two of them i don't think
she's better than zova and i don't think
silva's better than her i just think
they do two different things xbcj said
an interview with nerd street gamers
coming from a soba player myself i just
think she's super fun super new take on
the game i really think they nailed down
her style really well she makes you
scared to play against all her kit the
ultimate the dogs run out you you're
blinded while you're getting ran at you
don't have audio when you're getting
fought lots of stuff that's super
chilling with her kit any caster bach
noted there have been mixed results with
fade comps while it is still early
within the competitive scene where she
can be used it shows that there is
potential there and that she isn't the
mega star pick like silva or sky was
it's something that valerie has been
really trying to do with new agent
releases give people options and show
that there isn't just one meta to stick
to hopefully they keep this trend up
with the new agents they release after
this and balance the ones they already
have
you want colton here's my end board
challenge for you
explain to me on camera why or why not
you think i look like baby bae all right
you heard liz
nah
[Music]
capitalize on like this comparison
i challenge you colton not to use that
as an n board